I mean Nicholas Cage is a movie star
well
I don't know about that
if you go you're going to watch a
Nicholas Cage there are a lot of middle
ladies that get their panties wet over
him though
[Music]
so did you guys hear about Quentin
Tarantino saying that Marvel oh
yeah the stars of Marvel movies are not
movie stars yeah what are they oh like
well he's basically he's basically in
like um you know the reason why people
go to these movies is they want to see
Captain America yeah like they don't
want to see it's not because they're
there for it's like Ben Affleck it's
like yeah right they're not there to see
um Hemsworth they're there to see Thor
oh yeah oh I'm there to see Henry Cavill
as Superman or are you I'm there what
about Robert Patterson that's a stupid
perspective I'm I'm thinking I'm down
for Robert Downey Jr.'s as Tony Stark
you know what I mean I like Robert
Downey Jr no I think what happened is
people go to see Iron Man and then they
go oh that's cool that Robert Downey
yeah did that I think that's how I feel
oh okay I can see that I think it's it's
not what they go for but they leave with
a cool souvenir so I kind of agree with
what he's saying like because I'm
watching Batman regardless of who's
playing exactly because it's Batman or
Joker or whoever the [ __ ] or watch
anybody but then why would I guess I'll
call them a movie star yeah but some of
the actors are movie stars though yeah
pre-marvel right yeah yeah well like
Chris Hemsworth is definitely doing a
lot of [ __ ] outside what other movie of
Chris Hemsworth are you a big fan of I
actually uh uh enjoyed the recent army
ones that he did extraction extractions
yeah I thought those are dope it was
like fun Downey Jr is like a movie star
before he played well not exactly like
so he kind of had a falling out with the
industry because he had a drug problem
and then he was seen as maybe box office
poison for a while and then he went
blackface too it was an opportunity Iron
Man was an opportunity for him right so
then when he got Iron Man nobody gave a
[ __ ] until
the movie came out and everyone loved it
so then she only got paid half a million
dollars for Iron Man wow and then he and
then he was able to negotiate a [ __ ]
sick deal which is why you know West
Terence Howard in that same movie got
like 10 million or something like that
wow in the first one for being uh the
not war machine yet but yeah bro but I
think it does make sense like whoever
brings the most to the table it ends up
being that project so Marvel they're so
[ __ ] huge I think it feels like it
overshadows anything but um I think in
uh what movie was that where oh for
Django
um I think Will Smith auditioned right
and then when he auditioned to play
Django uh Will Smith is like this is
gonna be a Will Smith movie and
Tarantino's like no it's going to be a
Tarantino movie so it ended up being we
have to go with Jamie Foxx yeah so I
just think like two people said oh hell
no what happened so I think whatever is
like at the table whoever brings the
most will end up becoming the main thing
he's gonna call it Wild Wild West
I know him and a cowboy outfit's already
boxed off his nightmares
but no so like to further kind of what
territory was saying you know um Chris
Hemsworth with it was a movie called Men
In Black International that movie bombed
that was terrible right but but and you
know there's so many outlying factors
for why that happens but the idea that
he's saying is like if Tom Cruise is in
a movie everyone's going to see that
[ __ ] movie right is that does that
sound unfair I mean Nicholas Cage is a
movie star well
I don't know about that
if you go you're going to watch a
Nicolas Cage there are a lot of
middle-aged ladies that get their
panties wet over him though but it
scales down right because like the
Nicholas Cage is not you know the
biggest draw as you know right yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] Lord over there was a [ __ ]
eating grid
no but um so Hemsworth Hemsworth is not
like you just put his name on the
Marquee yeah you can get a certain
amount of guaranteed DVD sales or
whatever but you're not going to get
like these guaranteed box office like a
Tom Cruise yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
there's they were in the comics of the
conversation they're talking about how
there's only like three movie stars now
like where like you put their name on
and they're it's gold Denzel
yeah are those three considered then
like a-listers and like Chris Hemsworth
is like a b-lister or is that how that
works I don't know how that works
probably another one huh Tom Hanks is
out there I think they said well I think
they were just talking I don't know they
named everybody was talking about Crews
they're talking about like blockbuster
hits the Blockbuster guys yeah I don't
know if they mentioned Denzel but he's
definitely Tom Cruise is probably the
guy though what about Margot Robbie yeah
she's probably one of them yeah but that
that Brad Pitt maybe the new Harley
Quinn movie didn't do as well so [ __ ]
like that happens and then it kind of
Sully's like your resume huh yeah it
makes it less of a dunk because all
these Studio execs want is to like
better their odds so like they put you
in the movie instead of somebody else
because maybe it better is the odds it's
a success Matt Damon Matt Damon hey dude
definitely I bought a zoo that movie was
a box office smash well when he was
doing born like he was like the number
one guy he was in everything and then he
did that Mars movie
he that was a huge movie that was a sick
ass movie Scott movie I was [ __ ]
great but so then um so I don't know
that everyone really heard him because
um that was the interview with Tom
Segura right that was the interview with
Thompson Curry I was listening to that
one and then um so simulu Shane Chi star
came out and says if the only
Gatekeepers to movie stardom came from
Tarantino and Scorsese I would never
have had the opportunity to lead a 400
million plus movie I think that's kind
of his point yeah like I think what what
Tarantino was saying he was saying that
like right now the only thing that's
being made are Marvel superhero movies
or just not even Marvel but like just
superhero moves in general and like I
think everyone even as like moviegoers
like I love the Marvel series I love all
that stuff I nerd out over it but after
a while you're like can I see something
else bro like I want to watch other
movies that are not dealing with a comic
book character you know like whatever
happened to just a regular action movie
you don't really see much of those
anymore I mean people are getting butt
hurt about the word movie star yeah
because they're like hey I am a movie
star I was in a movie and I'm a star
yeah and I'm we made 400 million but
that's kind of the point right it's like
well yeah but you wouldn't have gotten
to be headlining a movie worth more
million if you weren't playing a Marvel
character yeah
it infuses so much [ __ ] money I don't
know that he was even I don't know that
he was aware of the full context or
whatever but that to me he just made
Tarantino's Point he'd be clapping back
a lot at people maybe that's one of
those things where TMZ just caught him
somewhere and they're like what do you
think about Tarantino saying you never
know he tweeted it but still yeah okay
oh [ __ ] but I remember like from that
interview that that headline from
Tarantino saying the only thing they're
making right now is Marvel movies and
it's like a well he's talking about real
budgets right yeah like yeah because do
a Tarantino movie he can do whatever the
[ __ ] he wants he gets hundreds of
millions of dollars to budget it out but
if you want to make some movie and it's
not a Marvel movie yeah good luck but
then don't you think like Martin
Scorsese and Quentin Tarantino if
they're talking about films as a whole
in the business like Motion Pictures in
me yeah exactly like those [ __ ]
they know what they're talking about
like they've seen it all like to a
certain degree I could really understand
whatever frustration they have is rooted
in a lot of [ __ ] that we don't hear on
the day like they're probably the ones
talking to big studios and financiers
and hearing back like no we're focusing
more on this right now and they're
trying to make movies that change
[ __ ] Cinema and they can't because
whatever is out of the you know they're
like oh we just lost them because they
want to finance superhero movies exactly
and they make so much money so like as a
business as a as a exec of a studio why
wouldn't you go all in on Marvel like
why wouldn't you they make too much
money Robert Downey Jr made a movie
called the judge just after
um end game right or I think it was I
think no this is not after end game this
is after Avengers Infinity War Infinity
War thank you and this movie made you
know it had a budget of 50 million
dollars it made worldwide 84 million not
very good right like you you don't want
to spend that much on a budget and then
have that little of an upswing sounds
good I know of people but that's not
they've spent money on on they're
looking for home runs they're looking
for homeless especially with the Robert
Downey yeah exactly so that's the point
right he wasn't Iron Man if this movie
was called Iron Man colon semicolon the
judge
this movie would have made it as a judge
400 million dollars there's no Iron Man
because this this stuff is our mythology
like people want to watch like Superman
and yes Henry cavill's greatest Superman
but people would watch it if it was
[ __ ] right anime Superman yeah it's
kind of like even athletes and teams
right like if you have like a LeBron
doesn't matter what team he goes to
you're gonna follow him legit like like
athlete star or whatever versus someone
that's just been on the Lakers for the
past 10 years you're like he's just part
of the Lakers or whatever you know yeah
yeah let me ask you guys this Mel Gibson
is a superstar but were you watching for
Jesus or were you watching for Mel
Gibson
I don't think he was in the movie he
wasn't in the movie he just directed it
are you watching first directorial so I
don't think
I don't think
all right we're done
that's it
I don't even think you watched it
[Music]
[Music]